Americus it provided a system is the
same
chronic no word for it in English old
people candy from way way back like way
back product pop okay what's the how do
I pronounce this kind of nutty maybe
like peanut buttery kind I feel like
doughnut II a little biscuit II soft on
the inside
crunchy on the outside it's perfect
tastes like the healthy version of
something good that was a kid I could
see myself just looking the outside of
this body come Ison it's a Fiat ego gets
raspberry flavored sapphire cakes this
looks like a bath soap which means I'm
excited to eat it like how delightful
this looks like it's out of like a fairy
tale mmm smells like perfume nothing our
favorite something ooh they're soft
ooh they're like marshmallow runes
now there's a texture I've never felt
because it's kind of hard to tell
visually what the texture is maybe this
will give you a little hint
just like you got it
but oh you need going maybe start to
back your thing on Frehley and candy
would stash you nuts
I like pistachios I like chocolate I
like Estonia this is gonna be great this
looks like a tootsie roll and on the
inside it's got pistachio stuff I guess
that's not a nice-looking piece of candy
took me about ten seconds to figure out
whether or not this was good
my conclusion it's okay it's very gooey
and gets kind of like all over your
mouth like I think like in between my
teeth and my gums there's still a lot of
chocolate and pistachio just sitting
there we gotta use pistachios and more
candy to move the stashes are expensive
and go psycho psycho meat which is birch
tree candy Kisuke which from the package
looks like it translates to log cut
leaves on it that's never a good sign
the candy don't give up hope it may look
like poop but it may not taste like I'm
no idea what I just put my mouth what is
this Burt's tree flavour so it really is
a log oh it tastes like a tree huh well
I'll be down trees are delicious so if I
lick a birch tree it's gonna taste like
this I think that's cool I think we're
gonna talk about for a reason because
fries don't taste very good
nice try to keep the tree thing alive I
wouldn't waste calories on this let's be
real
no American equivalent of this we need
to step up our birch tree
snack game Howard if these taste like
what life in Estonia is like super moist
and moist on the inside
just very more that the moistness I
don't know why I keep tomahawk
that's what impresses me about this
thing it's super moist on the inside and
our surprise